i never get into celebrity gossip
stories but i saw one it was trending on
twitter yesterday and it's in all the
newspapers and it actually i think sort
of matters
kim kardashian and kanye west
are reportedly headed for imminent
divorce
i i look i
i don't i wish them both well i'm
actually very sad to hear this
and i know a lot of other people are
very sad to hear this people seem to
actually devastated in the comment
sections
on social media and i thought why is it
you've got a thrice married
ex-porn star kim kardashian married to
a very eccentric rapper
why are people so shocked and saddened
that this marriage is coming apart
the reason is because our marriage
culture
has been so incredibly degraded right
marriage rates are at an
all-time low people
often expect to get divorced even if
they're if they get married
that their marriage actually seemed
relatively stable
and because kanye west is relatively
conservative for people in hollywood
not just because he put on the maga hat
but because he goes to church because he
practices religion because he
is vocal about that because apparently
when he was making that
that gospel album he told the the people
working on the album we said no
fornicating while you're working on this
album
i thought whoa man this is this is
pretty
conservative stuff
i i get it i it tells you a lot about
the state of this culture
that the west kardashian marriage
is something we're all hoping will last
as an instrument of stability or as
a symbol of stability and true love and
all that sort of thing and i do wish
them well and i hope they don't get
divorced it's very divorce is a very bad
thing
they got a lot of kids and and
as bizarre as their life is
it it will it will somehow
degrade the culture even further if they
if they get divorced i it will
there there is i i don't think that all
the fanboys and fan girls
who were complaining about this on
social media yesterday i i think that
comes from a genuine
a genuine cultural angst if you enjoyed
that break from disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video
[Music]
you